[Music]
there's a lot of networks there's one
called logo television network and this
is true it ran a documentary about
bronies if you haven't heard bronies are
adult men who are huge fans of the show
my little pony
I always thought bronies were kind of a
joke but then I saw this documentary
that they aired and I found it
fascinating check it out one of my
friends call me on skype one day and
said hey have you seen this show it's
called My Little Pony Friendship is
Magic and it's the internet is raving
about it you've got to see this show so
I put on another one and another one I
just couldn't get enough I wait till my
wife went to bed watch it my little pony
I am getting excited about my little
pony I wish I could bring him on a farm
Murdock I was like this this shows
amazing I'd feed him handful of oats and
wash their muscular haunches every day
just to see them smile what my little
pony I thought we were talking about
porn those guys are like those pony
cartoons those guys are sick it teaches
so many good things I am talking about
breeding male porn stars on a farm not
cartoon ponies my reputation is at stake
here
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we got a great show tonight
win it when you said brony documentary I
was hoping it wasn't that brony come in
here you bin